aquí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
nunca he sentido que tu perro es tu
sombra
muchos de ustedes se estarán preguntando
qué hace un perro acá en el escenario
pero en sí acá no hay una persona y un
perro hay un sujeto de seis patas
el 62% de los cordobeses tenemos perros
eso significa que 6 de cada 10 de
ustedes tienen uno
pero eso no nos hace un sujeto de seis
patas
un sujeto de seis patas nos hacemos
cuando
a ver a ver viste cuando vos llegás a tu
casa y tu perro te mueve la cola como si
se fuese de cadera
cuando te cruzas al kiosko del frente de
tu casa
volvés y tu perro te recibe como si
tuviese seguido hace una semana atrás
bueno eso es la fidelidad del perro
cuando nosotros no logramos poner a la
altura de esa fidelidad es cuando
empezamos a dejar de ser dos y nos
transformamos en uno
ella es erika es mi compañera de
aventuras con erika hemos vivido
muchísimas cosas largo recorrido en
montañas hemos hecho muchas exhibiciones
y hemos sacado muchas sonrisas a niños
de hecho con ella compartir la noche más
linda de mi vida me trajo los anillos
casamientos
y ni hablar el día que le presenté a mi
hijo
son sensaciones indescriptibles
pero con lo que compartimos más tiempo
es haciendo canicross
el canicross es un deporte federado
derivado del mushing de los deportes
trineo
como todo deporte trineo el perro debe
ir con un pre tal
que no la activa yo voy con un cinto de
tiro y vamos conectado con una correa
es un deporte de muchísima confianza
porque durante la carrera casi nunca nos
vemos a los ojos
ella gira las orejas para atrás
y está atenta a todos mi comando derecha
izquierda adelante atrás
y yo voy atento a todas las decisiones
que ella va tomando
el canicross en nosotros
empezó
un día frío
un día de lluvia
y la verdad
esas venían - y que estaba acostado y
y no quería entender realmente lo que
ella quería
pero si me están diciendo que era hora
de salir como hacemos habitualmente
entonces me pongo las zapatillas me
pongo la campera la subo al auto y nos
vamos al descampado donde corríamos
habitualmente
esas corrían seguían a las liebres se
metieran los charcos de agua
disfrutaban realmente el frío
y les veía en su estado más natural
siendo perros
entonces me queda una ficha
vuelvo a mi casa le doy de comer y hago
el ritual que hacemos habitualmente
una vez que se quedaron tranquilas me
voy a la casa de mi abuela
mi abuela
vive hace muchísimos años en si se rueda
y hace mucho tiempo que mira la vida
desde una ventana
en una charla de mates
me animó a preguntarle abuela
que se siente estar todo el día
encerrada
y se me mira suspira muy profundo como
buscando la respuesta en el alma
cimac a la voluntad me dice
y en ese momento
entiendo y salvando la distancia que mi
abuelo es mi abuela y mis perros son mis
perros
que el momento que yo salgo con ellos
es el momento y no importa si es una
hora
30 minutos 15 minutos no importa lo
importante es que compartimos ese tiempo
porque los perros
son animales sociales que significa
animales sociales que necesitan de su
manada y esa manada son ustedes
son animales jerárquicos necesitan de un
líder y necesitan compartir tiempo con
su líder y ese líder
son ustedes
y así nos fuimos sumando primeros
carreras de calles en donde yo iba
corriendo junto a erika y la gente me
algunos me decían ay qué bonito perro
pero muchos otros me decían cómo vas a
hacer correr ese perro y era muy difícil
contarle todo esto que le estoy contando
agitado
imagínense ustedes
que los perros
son animales de genética nómade qué
significa eso
y están preparados para correr
su antepasado el lobo
puede llegar a recorrer más de 100
kilómetros diarios para ver su
territorio
en el canicross es obligatorio que el
perro vaya adelante
el perro es quien te marca el ritmo o
sea que el perro no puede ir ahí atrás
siempre tiene que ir adelante
y esto es la idea de que intentamos
mostrar en cada carrera
así
sumamos primero una carrera de calle una
carrera de 30 y cada vez suma más gente
una organización se animó a dar dos
categorías
de ahí a un sudamericano y si ahí nos
encontramos en otros sudamericanos
y de repente junto a maría super indiana
eric y yo
estábamos en el mundial en el mundial en
polonia muchos de mis amigos me dicen
supera viajo en avión y yo todavía no
pero ojo
si ellas no podían entrar a la torre
yo no podía entrar la torre si ella no
podía entrar al museo yo tampoco podía
entrar al museo
porque estábamos juntos en esto
el mundial consiste en dos días el
primer día clasificatorio el segundo día
contra el reloj estábamos el segundo día
preparado para correr yo con la
testosterona acá porque bueno queríamos
mejorar el tiempo del primer día
me llaman
en polaco o en inglés no me acuerdo bien
pero no me acuerdo ni el idioma así que
maría que lo entendía me dijo te toca a
vos
entonces me pongo con erika gente las
pierde y la empiezo a agitar y erick a
así
25 segundos y yo la agita américa le
agitaba la agitaba y erika así
empezaba a correr los segundos y para mí
el tiempo corría más rápido normal
porque yo no veía quizás no quería
correr y como le conté si ella no quiere
correr se terminaba el mundial para
nosotros
faltando 10 segundos
erika cambia la postura
y con una chicharra de 5 4 3 2 1
erika gira sus orejas para atrás y sale
a toda velocidad y yo detrás de ella
fue la carrera más bonita de mi vida
porque descubrí que erika no importaba
estar en polonia no le importaba estar
en el mundial ni siquiera en un
sudamericano en una calle de calle o en
un trade
y se le importaba
que estamos corriendo juntos
en mi vida
he tenido una característica
la perseverancia
yo voy voy voy voy y hay muchos me dicen
que cada vez que cierro y voy
pero cuando estoy llegando al objetivo
y llegué
se me escapan de la mano trastabilló y
eso es por
la inseguridad
una seguridad que traigo o que traía
porque a partir de que vivo estas cosas
con erica
estos miedos
se han alejado
esta inseguridad
se han alejado como ahora
muchos de la gente que corre conmigo
canicross han encontrado en su perro ese
motivación una motivación que los hace
bajar de peso con la que dejaron de
fumar
esa motivación con la que han cruzado
grandes límites
pero el tiempo es tiempo
y
según momento en que yo le muestro
implemetar y ya no quiere correr
o al contrario quiere correr pero su
cuerpo no le da y llega el momento en
que
hay que jubilar la
a erika la jubilamos hace dos meses
ese momento es un momento muy duro
porque es como cortar un cordón
es decir le erika hoy te quedás acá
pero lo más lindo de todo
es que erika sigue siendo mi perra
sigue siendo en mi compañera
sigue siendo de mi casa
sigue siendo familia y como dice la
película
a la familia nunca se abandona
hoy
cuando lleguen a sus casas tómense un
ratito
tómense un ratito y miren a sus perros a
los ojos oa sus gatos luego a ese animal
con el que elegiste convivir
miralo
y vas a encontrar un compañero
y va a encontrar un amigo me encontrar
un pilar
mirarnos a los ojos y te aseguro
que te vas a transformar en un sujeto de
seis patas
cerca
[Música]
y